nothing with me baby attack hi my name
is markiplier this is hugo from its
software hi we had a go wait we could
start no this is fine this is definitely
the first time we've done this and we're
gonna keep going no matter what
hi in Wow great come yeah videogames do
its software has been around since 1991
yes I think so 91 yeah yeah how does do
maternal kind of like bring that a bit
further how does it elevate on what was
already a great game well uh really weak
Double Down triple down on everything
that people liked I think it was more
about chipping away that some of the
rough edges like objectively looking at
the game we made and saying how could we
make this better we start with areas of
improvement like the game did get
repetitive in the third act we did run
out of tricks to throw at the player so
overall we wanted to make sure that
every hour of the game all 20-plus hours
of it isn't just as engaging as the
verrat the beginning of the game for
example in the last level of the game we
will take you to a location you've never
been before throughout the entirety of
the game and meet ai you've never seen
before so we'll still be introducing
things right up until the very end
doom is like a Lamborghini we just want
to make sure that everybody we're gonna
teach everybody how to drive that car
because again when I think of a
Lamborghini I just think it's it's just
gonna be super tight a marvel of
engineering more of a Tesla man I I
think now is the time that I'm just
gonna dive into the game by the way
that's Shawn back there he's creeping up
no one be afraid he is supposed to be
there anywhere that I should start in
particular or right from the beginning
right from the beginning we're from the
good gum we're really excited ultra
nightmare maybe I'll start out
ultraviolence so to you sir
I'll give ultra miles ago I you know
I'll see what it is
[Music]
oh right into it I like that that's a
great intro by the way thank you
yeah is that final final oh yeah oh cool
I like that oh you had no aim-down-sight
here huh oh that's funky interesting
that Vega for March yes sir that's right
that's right okay okay all right let's
see what we do never mind I can't figure
oh there we only is that programmed to
do the the skull into the body the first
kill cuz that's the funniest one I
remember from the first trailer like
that that was the thing that everyone
was talking about Julian
it is definitely bloodier yeah this is
cool it feels like quick three Arena
which was like my favorite quick game by
the way oh you know one of my one of my
favorite also most memorable things from
the original doom was the the way the
walls moved and they had like faces in
them was viscerally horrifying and just
like really gave this sense of like
scope to the universe and the fact that
these are all doing that is just
punchable 'he's alright here's where you
got you guys said I was good at the game
and this is where I'm gonna start to be
real stupid oh of course I'm so dumb I
teach to see the double jump there too
ooh weapon mods are these gonna be like
the same weapon mods from the first game
or are there different there's new one
okay meat sick this is this is late game
mmm-hmm
you are about to meet a black belt how
we say that we level the player up to a
black belt level I'm about to meet a
black belt so apparently this is
difficult or something like that this is
farther in the game I've never seen I
have no idea what's happening
yada-yada-yada I am completely a freshly
born baby wandering into this literally
going into hell you're sending a baby
into hell how do you sleep enough Hey
hello hello I got Sentinel battery
that's for my base right so I can do
things there i trapped forever
my own hubris got me
cool all right good to know that I'm
still just as good as a war known this
I'll give you a pro tip a blood punch
will remove all the same cyber maybe
this is karma right our blood punch
indeed punch it's dead
what a [ __ ] punch everything's punched
based in this society I love it punch oh
I get it
punch I wasn't punching fast enough
punch perfect it's a skill to get into
this sister high are there's people what
is you oh what oh oh oh okay I'm gonna
die I was not ready for that
whatever you think I'm ready for this is
not the one I kill hit you
ooh that guy's that guy's good I was
marauder okay super heavy demon and
offensive power of host and two closest
he uses his shotguns to four places his
axe if that's all I've got nothing to
worry about
stop how am I gonna get to you which go
use my upgrade yeah at the range no I do
don't I buy both pure now gimme okay
well they didn't need it anyway
hi your turn now no you're gonna get it
okay oh I ran out of ammo of that you
are going to die I could summon a wolf -
I need you to slow down please you did
not
oh you summoned a wolf why didn't you
guys warn me okay
oh I'm gonna die this is how I die I do
not have blood punch ready all right
cool
good this guy's fun I didn't realize it
have to get serious now's the time to
play
nailed it did you see that the meathook
no this is not the right weapon meathook
that's my fist I'm hey listen bro oh
sorry
it's fine cut this I thought I tried to
do it through peaceful methods I didn't
realize this was a violent game now I'm
gonna get this okay what is that that's
what that is okay so what what oh that
hang on
I just want to eat look nailed it on the
best oh he hurts so good
all right you know I'm ignore everybody
else I'm gonna focus on this guy cuz
obviously he's a worthy opponent someone
a dmg that's be cheating well I wasn't
expecting him to I was just thinking
about other stuff you are so annoying
[Applause]
she is the right button I was looking
for not that one okay
okay
ah
[Music]
Wow that's just unfair
put your shield away you big baby okay
what a what a pile of turds wanna get
hit when his eyes flash cream I didn't I
don't need to know nothing all I need is
my bare hands and his dead body that's
not what I wanted oh shoot shoot what
you guys don't realize is this easy I'm
just making it look good oh god what
brick Oh next time yeah oh oh damn it
are you suck and I don't care how many
times okay I had a hundred health 50
Yarber he's very strong special smiles
yes finally no one's ever seen this yeah
no one will know what none of the press
well we'll see this until the game is
out yeah Wow
I feel so honored so lucky thrown into
the deep end of the pool left a flounder
ah hi you what's up Bubba how you doing
big guy I wanted to do some oh hi hello
oh shoot poins
you're about to meet a new enemy a new
enemy say it ain't so oh come here you
oh really
fascinating what where they all read oh
god that's still them oh well oh you're
tougher I can't chainsaw you is that a
big imp yeah is that the new enemy yeah
[Laughter]
let oh is it the man Cubist's or
whatever was the arch-vile yeah I was
close
okay so we're yet arch-vile where where
would you be Oh baby's big all right so
I got a fine dinner yeah okay oh well
good
know hey how you doing now
okay I did not want to be close to you
why oh my god oh my god oh my got you
you then you know insufficient fuel of
course it would be whoa where are you
whether this is the baby oh no no I was
stuck on something
behind me how did you get this Oh God
give me something with a mo
I guess nothing but skin and bones how
about easy Oh Oh aah all right I'm down
here now
that's term censure why okay I I did it
I'm a genius I am incredible in every
way how do I get here I'm gonna die now
I'm not a juice help so you would have
learned this but you need to get a rad
suit before you go in there suits for
babies I'm a man
I am the doom Slayer big and strong oh
nice suit
god is good I did it I'm the greatest no
there that looks like a climb Hey just
shoot that was something oh god I can't
crouch Kenneth what did I do
oh I did it gamer instincts did not lead
me astray okay well this is a Brit this
is pretty city this is pretty
sounds super cool
I missed okay well this isn't working
out that guy is way tougher than anyone
could handle let alone little of me Oh
big dude you well I got another life
does this dude die the same way I bet
not
he's so lucky
but he looks like he could out I am
gonna destroy my sty that was my bad I
have literally stood under him and just
ate his taint all right
okay now that I'm understanding perfect
understanding of every weapon system
possible fully cognizant of every single
nuanced intricacies of this game I am up
now apparently that guy's dead as he
should be as is obvious it would be that
guy's going to be hit yeah okay okay now
I'm feeling it up now that makes it not
what I wanted where am I going
I don't know I don't know I don't know
I'm gonna be stuck there's a great many
things about this that are scary and new
and I'm trying to just get by day by day
and I just hear laughing it that's all I
hear there it is again
this guy's
okay he's dead you come here
give your juices what's left you've dumb
monkey buses
oh I don't remember that that guy is
weird
oh I'm gonna die okay this is how it
happens oh no I want the fries no I miss
oh god hello you kill kill cheetah get
me out of here please swing me oh my god
oh you yeah and dig this you ever seen
someone be this good at a game before in
your life that was there no never
yeah thank you for the sir I need I did
deserve that you know if you saw what
happened why I went for glory is it the
monkey heart no that's impossible
god this is very much more insane than
the last game so the Vatican that again
is called a Jew hunter and you will have
to disable his slip the names are so
2016 this is doomed 2020 oh no how does
plan I every single bit of Health I got
just went away please not like this not
like this not while I'm an idiot oh this
guy I cannot believe how are you still
here
No oh my god did you see that
oh yeah sure what I'm gonna need that
later you don't know what I need I
needed to feel safe you ever consider
that well I'm gonna get oh he's dead
I've done it I'm the greatest yeah you
might not I mean you you're gonna be
picking up a lot of vfg ammo so we make
the encounters account for that
yeah well BFG amaz for cheaters I don't
use the BFG I agree with you
yeah cheapens the experience hello there
I am just the best no no no no I just
was having fun no I'm teasing it where's
my BFG noggin
no I didn't you shot it at the floor now
you there's just you just me mano a mano
as as as it was always meant to be
except this one can take any of you here
get out of here get out of here all
right
oh this guy good good out of here and
have you interrupting my glorious battle
oh yeah you can't okay so if I remember
my years at school and the ways of
killing we're pretty go
Oh God there is where the Frick did he
go okay well I definitely hit you both
of those times out Oh God mine don't so
when's he due this green eye thing huh
seems like never seems like it was never
oh he came in early okay all right here
we go
we're gonna just clear oh god yes yes
green I wish you earned that I caught
him with the BFG good shot oh my god
that is the fastest way to kill oh but
it's really hard and I did it I'm not
kissing you back here
this is really impressive what you're
doing you're not even fully upgraded
you're sitting on combat points you
don't know all the months you don't know
how to skill shots for every heavy that
you're killing right now and you are
[ __ ] succeeding if you guys couldn't
hear that that was just straight 100
percent praise from Hyuga creative
director doom eternal said I'm doing a
great job for someone who has no idea
what they're doing I did it I can't
believe we did that I can't either
because that was that was ultraviolence
and there's two more difficult things a
level beyond that well there's there's a
nightmare hmm and then ultra nightmare
is nightmare but you're only allowed to
have one life which I don't see how
anyone is gonna do that nightmare is
actually really fun um I think that
that'll wrap up my play session of this
game um yeah just thank you so much for
letting me give this a try all of my
[ __ ] talking was in the moment ah very
stressful but hey the game is great the
feel is great the play style is great
like if you are worried that doom
eternal is not gonna be as fun to play
as doom
dude it's more fun like this is easily
more fun and and if you're not for the
type of person that likes all the
intricate gunplay don't play it at the
level I was playing I was playing second
hardest difficulty so if you're if you
were looking at that and being like oh I
can do that don't worry there's another
one above it so there's something for
everybody
as we said though it's like a combat
puzzle that's worth your time to solve
we're giving you something to master
yeah and there's a lot of cool things to
see in there and there's a lot of things
to play with so yeah thank you
Hugo thank you so much thank you Sean
back there for being the person that
everyone in the comments is gonna be
like out there the whole time yeah
thanks so much bye-bye
[Music]